you know how to do a middle finger to
the mean people of Internet no cuz your
cat hi guys my name is Tara chambers and
this is Tara's never seen in the last
video somebody commented just camera
owned anything other than king tops put
some clothes on so I thought I would not
wear a tank top for this episode just so
that make some people happy oh wait I am
where you take Tom that guy today I
watching Robocop after I posted the Bill
& Ted's Excellent Adventure
everyone was like why didn't you do
Robocop subscribe button lab it's the
politics of Twitter guys you have to
follow the politics of Twitter I imagine
it's just gonna be like an ATZ action
film I think with robots let's get
started
Oh Panama's never seen ok this was way
more silly and more of a comedy than I
thought it was going to be also way more
brutal than I thought it was going to be
like guns are blowing off parts of
people's bodies no silly the practical
effects in the makeup and the robot
models were super fun and like really
great to watch I know I say this in
every connection video ever but it was
not what I was expecting I just tweeted
out you all have 20 minutes
give me your specific predictions on how
you think I'll react to Robocop I will
be looking at my phone until then it was
out there and we shall see I really
enjoyed media break the fake news show
his media break you give us three
minutes we'll give you the world that's
what she said the story itself I don't
think is very detailed it's very like oh
there's robot cops oh it's the main cop
oh he becomes the robot cop well then
the robot cop asset buys the other robot
cops and then there's the corruption in
the police station and the government
and then all is well since this sub is
like very yeah that's what I expected
you see Murphy who's transferred to this
you know dingy police station in Detroit
he gets his new partner Lewis and
there's just like a bunch of like
exposition then you're introduced to the
first robot cop I'm getting a very like
Bioshock
vibe room from ed-209 send he shoot and
kill but this really intense Bob is like
too bad about kitty huh that's life in
the big city let me think about all the
times that I've seen a human get shot
down and killed by a giant robot 0c a
male to zero great okay now it has
cleared up not what life in a big city
so this guy Robert dick is the one who
created the ed-209 program and Bob Bobby
is coming in with the new
Robocop design typical villain versus
typical good guy even though Bobby's
kind of a jerk too so they're both just
jerk dude but to the new Robocop they
need a person to volunteer they're like
no one's gonna want to do this give up
like their whole life to be this robot
in the next scene Murphy is talking to
Luis about how his son needs a good role
model and you're like there we go check
there's just really funny scene where
Luis and Murphy go after these bad guys
who have robbed this bank and Luis has
this one guy at gunpoint and he was just
peeing out in the open and she gets
distracted by his penis looks down at it
and he like punches are out it's like oh
girl always happening happens to be my
swing
that could be a mistake don't get
distracted by penises so Murphy is there
like has his gun out of the bad guys and
Louis's you know knocked out somewhere
I'm out of penis shop and they start
shooting Murphy and they shoot his hand
up and then he pulls it up but it's just
a stump a bloody stump and then they
shoot his arm off and then they start
shooting his chest bunch and then they
shoot a bullet through his brain so I
mean he's gone right right right
no they rushed him to the hospital to
turn him into Robocop but like at that
point what are you taking from him I
write down his blue eyes but then yeah
they do actually end up taking his blue
eyes from him so one part to where they
were able to save the other arm and then
Bob comes in and he's like no no don't
say it get rid of that arm so he's just
like full robot the back of his head is
robot in the front of his head is human
so I know he has some memories I'm not
trying to read into it too much here
because I know it's Robocop was not you
know a science thesis paper what are
they salvage out of his brain to have
memories still and then they were like
oh we're gonna zap his memories anyway
I'm confused at why they needed a human
I know to further the story but I just
to this point Murphy has been like
fighting crime and doing really great in
the city but he's having these small
little flashbacks out about when he's
not really supposed to be out and about
and he goes and he catches one of the
guys who was like shooting at him and
he's got all these flashbacks going on
so he goes to his home where his wife
and son and him lived and it's for sale
oh no so bad and apparently the wife
like started over commuting dead to them
and so at this point you're like no he's
never gonna see this kid again no but
also you see his house for sale and
there's like birch flowers everywhere in
garbage and stuff and you walk in it's
like oh it's for sale these Realtors
really didn't do a good job with this
they're never gonna sell it for market
values and at that point I really wish
the movie would a completely different
direction and he just fixed up the hole
so this is what you think kid got a lot
of money Robocop the interior designer
on HGTV dick
the bad guy and then he's got a lackey
and the lackey goes to Bob's house
shoots his legs a bunch of time and then
blows his house up and then I realized
that the Lackey is the dad from that 70s
show
Robo Cop goes out and takes outlets like
Coke Factory and he sees the dads in
that 70 show there and he's about to
kill him and then he's like don't kill
me dick is the bad guy I love that in
the beginning he's got his three main
things that he has to do like uphold
protect and serve and voila
goes to arrest dick and he's like you
know what the fourth word is you can't
arrest me but is a big surprise because
it obviously is a guy under a suit it's
not a robot and he does a really good
job most the time it's like portraying a
robot but sometimes when he is shutting
down and he's just like okay let's get
ready
2:09 comes in and starts they fight each
other and it's really funny because
it'll go to like full-size Robocop to
like model ed and then you can tell that
they're models and then like at one
point Robocop go through some blast and
then you can just see that it's a dummy
and and then Robocop those stairs and Ed
can't do stairs and so he just like
falls on his back and flail I'm like
same same that's how I feel about stairs
Oh Patricia told everyone that Robocop
is bad and so everyone's like shooting
at him and then Luis saves him and they
go to this dark secluded weird warehouse
factory place you know warehouse
factories I wrote fake news is hilarious
and I mean the fake news site but also
bad guys got a military fat man fat man
is from fallout I used the F word faggot
product of its time
so some time does buy and Lewis is
asleep on a pile of sticks she shows up
I love Lee your car is right there just
sleep in the back of your car could have
found a better bag so then no you know
what I'm just really still in the stick
thing why could she not find a better
bed her car was right there she's lying
on a pile of sticks like there's a small
blanket
between her the pile of sticks ooh just
like my childhood home
one of the with cousin the bad guys show
up Emil drives into toxic waste and ends
up in like two point five seconds of
having contact with the toxic waste
looks like sloth from the Goonies
I see jammers ever seen for letting me
know what that reference even means one
of the bad guys drops ruble on Robocop
and then Robo plops club Robo claps
claps on over to clearance spikes him in
the neck with his cool spiky thing best
weapon by far the Robocop has which is
just shot to pieces and she looks out
but she's like Murphy I'm a mess I just
like say but the way she says it is kind
of like a weird like 70s sitcom like
Murphy I'm a mess that's been everyone
laughs in the studio audience it was
great
Robocop goes to kill dick he's like you
still can't kill me because I work here
the president oh the company is like
dick you're fired
attendee shoots him and he falls out of
the window and the graphic things are
going to support whatever something was
like it's not graphics camera it's a
movie is not a video game sorry I
obviously don't know what anything is
the special effects are hilarious so I
loved it okay let's see what these
predictions are I'll feel like breaking
windows yeah yeah just when 80209 shoots
the executive in the boardroom you will
laugh so hard you almost cried but
actually I watched the movie last night
I'm filming it today this morning when
that happens though I was like I need to
document how he looks like took pictures
and that's this is how I look women said
you will know how Robocop I did I mean
that's just such a good prediction
you'll think it's so corny you'll beg
Doug to do a nostalgia critic review on
it I mean I think there's a lot of
material in here so I think this would
be a great episode for nostalgia critic
I predict you're going to get I'll buy
this for a dollar stuck in your head for
a while second prediction you will love
this ridiculous movie I really really
enjoyed it and I forgot to mention that
I'll buy this for a dollar just like
this fake TV show that they have it will
surely recognize the Jesus allegory but
the original social satire elements
might pass you by very much a product
time I mean I do know that Detroit was
in a bad place at that time and a lot of
American cities were in a bad place and
is the rich get richer and so you you've
got a crazy company involved with
everything who even control the police
there are a security company they
shouldn't have acted like control over
the police of the city of Detroit so
there's like a lot of great elements
there and I think that was mainly what I
took from it can guns really do that
much to a human body yes I feel that
very hard I think you'll be surprised at
the film is more clever parody and less
mindless action oh really
you'll turn into a robot okay I got so
many responses this is so cool I'm
definitely going to keep doing this that
was a blast
thank you for giving me your prediction
this morning I uploaded a video on my
personal channel tamerlan chambers at
youtube.com so check that out thank you
so much for watching and I will see you
very soon
[Music]
[Applause]